those monster earthquakes in turkey and
Syria are causing many Americans to take
a closer look at the potential dangers
right here at home especially if they
live in a quake prone area like Southern
California for years there L.A county
and other areas have required a crucial
retrofit to reinforce existing buildings
before what seismologists say is in all
but certain event another devastating
quake in that part of the country Omar
via Franca now looks at how that effort
is progressing
these are not the most sound buildings
you can ask for Kyle torgay is preparing
la for the big one if it shakes how does
it fail well the building essentially
pancakes the structural assessor is
trying to shore up homes ahead of a
potentially massive earthquake which
seismologists say isn't a question of if
but when at the time that these
buildings were designed and built they
didn't have codes that required seismic
design as a factor so here in the
distance we see the San Andreas fault
this is what a magnitude 7.8 earthquake
near Los Angeles could look like the
ground is literally moving up and down
but it's also moving sideways as these
waves are coming through the Basin it's
the same magnitude Quake that rocks
turkey and Syria earlier this month
structural engineer kit Miyamoto went to
Turkey to survey the damage it surviving
me like a picture from a Hiroshima
nuclear blast mile after miles of a
completely flattened out do you feel
that Southern California is on borrowed
time when it comes to a big earthquake
that's 100 guarantee I mean there will
be a gigantic earthquake happen in
Southern California La has mandates to
retrofit thousands of structures known
as soft story and non-ductile concrete
buildings the same kind that collapsed
in Turkey Tor Jay says it's a Race
Against Time how many of these are
around there's an estimated 20 000
buildings or more in L.A County
California building code already
requires new construction to better
withstand earthquakes but for many older
buildings across Los Angeles the
deadline to retrofit in some cases is 25
years away but assessors like torje urge
landlords and homeowners to act now it's
expensive to to do these retrofits but
you have tenants that you've lost that's
the biggest loss you can have for CBS
mornings Omar via Franca Los Angeles